all right David yeah David welcome back
again
so tell me what's uh what's been going
on I haven't seen you in quite a while
um I've basically been taking care of my
friend
he's uh
he he's he's 66. he can't walk he's
diabetic I've been putting everything
into that you know uh I I do everything
for him is it helping you helping
somebody else he pays me sometimes yeah
yeah but I do more like as friendship
you know yeah yeah just just having
somebody that you're yeah looking out
for sometimes can help you yeah yeah
it's helping me too yeah stay on track
how's your mental state been not too
great
it's uh I've been
going through little mental breakdowns
here and there more lately than than
before you know I haven't
cut myself but yeah yeah so uh but yeah
I just been going through a little
mental breakdowns with people's actions
towards me and so this this whole
neighborhood is it's crazy yeah it's
just runs down here yeah so if you're
trying to stay sane yeah yeah I'm trying
to do something right you know and
you're staying in the hotel across the
street oh on and off yeah yeah
basically that's my base which is
basically like an insane asylum yeah
yeah yeah
you know
but what are your plans what plans to uh
um just leave the you know leave that
late for a minute because
it's just I don't know I'm a country boy
so I like you know I'd rather go back to
the country just kid Rose no place for
you nah I've been here too long been
here 20 some years so
it's time to go where will you go
probably Bakersfield Maricopa or Ventura
uh Ventura County you have a friend up
there yeah I got a couple friends here
that's nice yeah so
can help you get up there yeah
yeah and uh
the drug use is still oh yeah it's it's
pretty heavy right now because of all
the situations I'm I mean whatever
whatever there's drugs where you're
going too yeah yeah exactly exactly
but uh yeah no no no purchase I haven't
purchased nothing lately so you know
you talk to your family at all yeah my
sister
yeah I I talked to her maybe three
months ago but I pretty much lost
contact with everybody right now I'm
just pretty much just trying to stay
away from people you know
just just because of my own my own
actions my my own thinking you know are
you on any psych medications yeah yeah
and you take them I could get in a shot
form well you do yeah yeah it's it's it
lasts for um uh three months at a time
yeah I remember you were telling me at
one point they were having a hard time
getting your
yeah the dose of that yeah that you
needed right yeah you know that's gonna
make it tough yeah
yeah but you haven't been like cutting
yourself like you were nah I did I did
about I was scared about a month ago
that second video we did was yeah yeah
and
I haven't done none since there yeah
I've been I've been well off on that
that's good yeah sure
in general your mental state is getting
better or uh saying the same or worse
I'm trying to make it better that's why
I'm gonna
leave La for a minute you know you think
the drug use is making the mentality yes
yeah it's making it worse yeah it's it's
interesting because after doing so many
of these I I see how the mental state
brings on the drug use yeah and the drug
use makes the mental state worse right
right and it's like the whole thing is
just a right and now I'm rocking back
and forth because of the drugs oh is
that right yeah it's something that I
picked up I don't know how yeah yeah no
I've seen a million different ticks yeah
behaviors and
yeah it's always a sign you have
something going on like that yeah
but yeah everything else I'm just trying
to I'm coming back but I'm just gonna
leave for a minute you know I'm just
gonna yeah know if it makes you happier
relocate you know it's got nothing for
you it's nothing nothing for nobody out
here man yes
it's all bad this is the bottom yeah
[Music]
how old do you know uh 42 42 yeah what
would you like to see it happen like in
the next 15 years uh well I know last
time I seen you I had got a hernia from
working out and I gotta go to surgery in
a couple in a month next month that's no
big deal yeah so I gotta be back for
that you know
um what was the question
no just like whatever you want to do in
five years oh in five years I want to be
working I'm gonna be working I want to
be um
like just working have my own place
when's the last time you had your your
own job ah man I was 16. really yeah
16. so all the drug use and the mental
yeah it just gets in the way of wow
yeah I do
and I'm doing I'm dealing with like
I think a couple demons I'm not sure but
I believe in that you know and I believe
I'm dealing with a couple of
because uh in there in the in the hotel
I see I hear people screaming and it's
not there because I I'll ask my friend
hey did you just hear that and he said
no so I know it's me you know
I know it's I know it's I know I'm
hearing new things you know
this is it's it's wow
yeah
and the combination of medications
you're
yeah taking yeah as well as the drug use
right right who knows what that's going
to create all right
yeah
I I'm trying to prevent a bombshell that
happened you know like me doing one of
my episodes is just going off because
this this might be a bad one if I if I
go off on you know
what's been building up lately what kind
of ideas do you get in your head
sometimes your darkest just you smashing
against the wall or something you know
not hurting nobody just just going just
hurting myself you know just just get it
out of my system most of your
most of your thoughts directed at
yourself yeah rather than someone else
yeah
I guess that'll keep you out of prison
yeah mental mental health is a big deal
isn't it yeah if you've had this this
trouble since you were a kid yeah yeah
you think you're born I didn't know yeah
I was born with it I was born with so
much cocaine in my system that they had
to Wing me off I believe that's what I
was told I had to get weaned off it and
oh
yeah I've always had these mental
problems but I never had knew how to
announce or tell my mom about what was
going on with me you know I was always
in special ed so they knew something was
wrong on that part but they never knew
anything was mental I found that out
when I was 18 when I went to prison
I found out I had a serious mental and
when you see your mom that's not your
biological mom no she's uh my adoptable
you're a biological mom did you ever
know no she never met her you heard that
she was on coke yeah I heard her her
yeah she was on quote Yeah
yeah
and your dad oh my dad I never met him
either oh my my adopted that he was
great he was a good person
but you so you had a good childhood yes
yes but you just biologically you might
have yeah some things that yeah because
I was adopted in a family with we had
nine brothers and sisters so
we had a lot of competition with
um you know who got the most attention
you know they're all adopted yeah yeah
yeah it was we were all seeking
attention back then it was just not
enough for us because there was too many
kids you know we were just too many too
many of us
you know
but yeah and the working out helps you
yeah it does right now it sucks because
I can't work out and you know I got
honey oh the hernia yeah slows you down
yeah yeah
what's your biggest fear now my biggest
fear going back to jail
just doing something stupid and going
back you know
you don't need that yeah
you know I met you probably what two
years ago yeah about two years ago what
have you learned in the last two years
anything
nasty
basically a lot of Street wise stuff
street street yeah Street survival but
nothing like to benefit me only things
that benefit me in this neighborhood you
know what I'm saying like I mean down
here everything just revolves around
drugs right drugs and yeah violence and
all that but yeah I just
I know how to do this but I'm just
trying to look for a different way out
man this is just it's a great thing to
realize and this is a dead end yeah this
is dead anyway no
and I had a friend he just he just
passed away he shot up crystalline guy
Crystal yeah and I've known him for like
19 years
yeah he uh he had fitting on him yeah so
and he just passed away that opened my
eyes you know to slow down at least
on everything now yeah yeah
dangerous world yeah
all right David well I wish you the best
of luck in
Bakersfield yeah
you deserve a break yeah had a rough
road yeah it's been rough been real
rough
hmm
all right David thank you so much